[Musique]
il est 6 heures du matin à tanger la
ville semble encore endormis mais au
cimetière certains sont déjà debout
ces adolescents ont passé la nuit parmi
les tombes ils sont plus d'une centaine
âgés de 15 à 25 ans à vivre ici les
tombes sont bâchées en guise de toit et
pour dormir un simple carton les sépare
des ossements mohamed à 23 ans il est
issu d'une famille pauvre des environs
de fès c'est ici que j'ai dormi toute la
nuit et pourquoi tu dors ici j'ai pas le
choix j'ai pas d'argent c'est la
première fois que je suis dans le
cimetière
on les appelle les harragas en français
les brûleurs de frontières parce qu'ils
ont tous le même rêve embarqué
clandestinement à bord d'un ferry pour
rejoindre l'espagne l'eldorado européen
ils viennent de tout le maroc pour fuir
la misère
on doit se débrouiller tout seul pour
s'en sortir
mes parents sont pauvres il n'y a rien à
faire au maroc et l'état ne nous donne
pas de travail va essayer de partir oui
ce matin encore pas de petit déjeuner
pour mohamed et son ami hassine 17 ans
ils n'ont pas un sou en poche mais
toujours le même rituel
ils prennent la direction du port ils
vont tenter leur chance ils vont essayer
de monter dans un camion clandestinement
sur la tête de mon dieu j'espère que je
vais partir si ça marche je ferai des
folies
[Applaudissements]
leur technique est toujours la même ce
poster à 2 km de l'entrée du port loin
des douaniers et attendre qu'un camion
passe pour s'y cacher ma technique dès
qu'un camion s'arrête au feu rouge
je cours je me cache sur les cieux et je
bouge plus quelques minutes plus tard un
camion arrive
mohamed et yacine tentent leur chance
mais ils ne sont pas les seuls
surgie de nulle part une nuée d'enfants
temps de s'agripper sous le châssis trop
nombreux ils n'ont pas le temps le
camion redémarre
cinq gamins d'à peine 12 ans se sont
accrochés à l'arrière de la remorque il
espère naïvement entrer dans le port de
cette manière
un deuxième camion se présente mais là
encore aucun jeune n'a le temps de
monter ils recommenceront cette nuit
demain et après demain s'il le faut
les adolescents trompe la mort ils
seraient environ 2000 à tanger à prendre
des risques insensés pour traverser le
détroit de gibraltar
c'est un nouveau phénomène au maroc car
c'est tout jeunes candidats au départ
n'utilise pas les filières classiques de
l'immigration clandestine
ils n'ont pas les moyens de payer un
passeur qui demande entre 400 et 7000
euros
combien réussi sept as passé il n'existe
aucune statistique précise
[Musique]
mais les autorités sont dépassées car se
cacher sous un camion n'est pas en soi
un délit
les policiers arrêtent donc rarement ces
jeunes une centaine tous les ans mais
les gamins se méfie il affirme que pour
les dissuader de recommencer
les policiers les brutalisent
ce groupe d'une dizaine de jeunes à
trouver refuge dans cette décharge il y
a quelques jours un des leurs s'est fait
arrêter il raconte comment les policiers
lui aurait cassé la jambe en le frappant
4e et or j'étais sous le camion ils
m'ont tiré de dessous pour que je sorte
c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé
et après ils m'ont emmené au
commissariat et m'ont battu
ils m'ont massacrés ils ne m'ont même
pas donné à manger même pas un bout de
pain rien du tout moi si je fais tout ça
c'est parce que mes parents sont pauvres
c'est pour eux que je veux partir on
mange ensemble on dort ensemble et on
tentera de partir ensemble
inch'allah
[Musique]
ouais
malgré les risques mohammad yassine sont
persuadés qu'ils vivront mieux en europe
au maroc le salaire moyen est de 180
euros en france et en espagne c'est dix
fois plus pour eux c'est un rêve
regarde là bas c'est l'espagne quand on
voit les immigrés qui arrivent avec leur
argent et qui frime avec leur voiture en
mettant la musique à fond
ça me fait envie la plupart du temps ils
sont bien fringué il sombra de belles
nanas ils ont une famille eux et donc
quand on voit tous alors qu'ici on ne
gagne que 5 euros franchement qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec 5 euros rien et
c'est pour ça que ça nous donne envie de
partir tout ça ça nous attire vers
l'europe je vais monter dans un camion
et si ça marche tant mieux mais si on
shoppe je reviendrai j'essaierai
toujours de partir comme empêcher ces
jeunes de tenter ce voyage à hauts
risques à tanger l'une des seules
personnes à s'occuper de ses enfants des
rues vite ici sur les hauteurs de la
ville dans le quartier des riches
propriétés de la bourgeoisie marocaine
c'est dans cette grande villa qu'habite
mounira elalamy les multimilliardaires
son mari est l'héritier d'un des plus
grands groupes industriels du maroc
c'est le roi de l'aluminium
mais cet enfant de mai 68 qui a fait
toutes ses études en france ne veut pas
rester les bras croisés à vivre de ses
rentes
mounira est avant tout une militante on
la surnomme la milliardaire rouge les
repères identitaires de mon milieu c'est
du travail
ça n'est pas de se bastonner ou d'aller
acheter les marques ou de feu de faire
du shopping avec l'argent de mon mari
est d'ailleurs il est d'accord avec moi
là dessus qu'il faut redistribuer et qu'
il n'y a pas besoin de vivre dans le
clinquant on se sentir exister
mounir a créé une association qui
recueille les enfants des rues les
candidats au départ plusieurs fois par
semaine elle se rend sur le port de
tanger à la recherche des jeunes
clandestins
cette dessous de sous dans les rouages
que tu vas en dessous c'est très
dangereux il ya beaucoup qui sont
asphyxiés qui sont écrasés qui tombent
quand le camion roule vraiment un
un suicide en direct mounira sait
parfaitement où elle est dans un coin
discret au pied des remparts qui
entourent le port un groupe d'une
vingtaine de gamins et rassembler ils
attendent que les camions arrivent a
préféré rester dans la rue comme ça
toute la journée vous voulez pas aller à
l'école
est-ce que tu va nous emmener à
l'association oui tu vas pas nous
emmener chez les flics
tu ne sais pas qui je suis je suis
madame l ami de l'association darna je
ne vais pas l'emmener à la police tous
ceux qui viennent avec moi son livre ils
ne sont pas maltraités dans le groupe
mounir a reconnaît un jeune garçon dont
elle s'est déjà occupée il y avait
pourtant promis qu'il n'essaierait plus
jamais de tenter la traversée
bonjour tu le connais pourquoi tu viens
ici pourquoi tu n'es pas dans mon
association
qu'est ce que tu vas faire c'est quoi ce
baluchon est ce que tu vas essayer de
monter dans un camion
laisse moi te dire quelque chose tu vas
être maltraités moi je te dis ça car je
sais de quoi je parle
il n'y a pas mieux que son pays que de
rester au pays
pourquoi vous ne montez pas qu'est ce
que vous avez comme perspective si vous
restez ici dans la rue qui va s'occuper
de vous de votre futur et du coup je
choléra tendent à les monter aujourd'hui
montmirail contente elle a réussi à
convaincre huit enfants de venir passer
quelques jours dans son association où
ils pourront se nourrir et se laver
quelques jours où elle tentera de les
dissuader de quitter leur pays
quatre pôles à ça pourquoi tu es parti
de chez toi hein pourquoi mon père me
tape dessus je suis battu un ton père te
bats c'est normal ils ont le droit de
nous battre ce sont nos parents
alors tu es en train de fuir tes parents
à l'arrivée sur les huit enfants deux
seulement sont restés dans la voiture
les autres sur descendu au pourrissement
et elle inquiète ont fait il a dit vous
avez sans mon fils leur crainte c'est
que je leur mette à la pause ils ont
peur de ça parce que probablement
l'expérience qu'ils ont tué la police et
patrick et des drogues et je crois que
tous les pays un comme ça il conseille
et abate alors pour les protéger des
violences de la rue
mounira héberge tous ces enfants dans
cette grande maison bleue qui donne sur
le détroit de gibraltar
elle tente de leur faire oublier leur
envie de partir la rentrée ils sont 160
entre 9 et 19 ans à vivre ici elle les
nourrit leur offre un toit et tente de
combler leurs manques affectifs
tous les jours je vais dans leur classe
et leur dire bonjour et ils ont besoin
de ce big boi ce qu'ils ont un énorme
besoin d'amour parce que la plupart sont
des enfants en rupture qui ont pas eu
cette maman quand nous on a eu après la
mer méditerranée à la mer
ces enfants ont déjà tous tentés de
partir au moins une fois
d'ailleurs quand il arrive à
l'association leurs premiers dessins
représentent toujours les bateaux et la
mère et pour les retenir mounira et son
mari sont très généreux chaque année ils
dépensent 100 mille euros pour cette
association car ce foyer n'est pas
seulement un hébergement
le meilleur moyen d'en citer ses enfants
à rester au pays
c'est de les scolariser pour cela mounir
a créé une école car la plupart ne
savent ni lire ni écrire ici 1 me
[Musique]
après à l'école mais ça ne s'arrête pas
là 52 personnes travaillaient à temps
plein pour encadrer les enfants y avait
un petit gars ici on apprend aussi des
métiers comme boulanger serveurs
menuisier ou même couturier des métiers
pour lesquels au maroc
on a besoin de main d'oeuvre
qui a le droit de circuler ça sauf
qu'avant il faut avoir des
qualifications comme ça tu au moins tu
as des armes pour ne pas subir mais pour
décider de ce que tu es capable
et montrer ce que tu capable de faire
hassan est arrivé il ya quelques mois
depuis qu'il est là il veut monter son
entreprise
oui j'étais pourquoi tu étais dans la
rue il y avait des problèmes dans la
famille mon père battait ma mère tu es
si les partis clandestinement
j'ai essayé plusieurs fois au port et
maintenant est ce que tu m'as encore
essayer non pourquoi
parce que maintenant je sais que je vais
travailler
les jeunes peuvent rester jusqu'à trois
ans ici mais mounira c'est qu'ils sont
extrêmement instables à chaque instant
ils sont tentés de repartir
précieux trésor ce sont nos enfants
chaque fois que j'en pêche à l'enfant de
monter dans un camion et de risquer sa
vie
c'est une victoire mais c'est une
victoire que comme je les réinsérer
professionnellement tout le reste du
temps c'est fragile chaque année
montmirat trouvent du travail à une
soixantaine de jeunes mais sur les 160
enfants que compte l'association
une vingtaine retourneront dans la rue
définitivement
au vieux cimetière de tanger mohamed
yassine les deux jeunes que nous avions
suivi au début de ce reportage s'apprête
à supporter une nouvelle nuit dans le
froid
cela fait deux semaines qu'ils sont là
et n'ont toujours pas réussi à passer en
espagne mais il aurait honte de rentrer
chez eux
comment on va faire pour rentrer avec
cette tête chez nos parents les
chaussures sont bousillés les cheveux
sont sales les vêtements sont noirs
quand tu veux qu'on rentre dans cet état
j'aimerais bien que ça se termine cette
histoire je ne sais pas comment ça va se
terminer
on est là on est assis on fout rien il
ya le chômage c'est à cause de ça qu'on
essaie partir chaque année environ 650
marocains trouvent la mort en voulant
traverser le détroit de gibraltar
[Musique]